You know what? This is such
a deep part of my childhood.
I can't go to who's hotter
in the Brady Bunch.
Yeah.
That's too hard?
Well maybe Cindy, but Cindy
may have hit rough times.
You know,
youngest child syndrome.
Do you wanna see
Brady Bunches now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I go Alice.
I remember when-
I'm an Alice guy.
Oh my God.
Fucking Ann B. Davis?
Goddamn right.
You're an Ann B.
Davis guy all day.
Call me Sam the Butcher.
It's The Bonfire, Comedy
Central Radio, Sirius XM 95.
It's very important.
Jacob is getting us
all wired up, how important.
Where is he? Aw man,
he would love that you did that.
How much did I nail it?
Did what?
We're saying Comedy
Central Radio, Sirius XM 95.
Oh, you identified.
Yes.
Just to make sure we weren't
a communist radio station
in the 30s.
Yeah. This has been taken over
by Russian people.
No, don't do the voice.
You know what I think
we can stop?
I think we can stop saying,
"Comedy Central Radio,
Sirius XM 95, Big Jay Oakerson,
Dan Soder,"
every time we come back in.
People know.
I think it's not-
After the first one ...
They get it by this point.
You just said it.
Yeah, see.
Yeah.
Set it up.
But we say it every time.
It's moronic.
Our guests joining us
in the studio right now,
Pete Holmes and Judd Apatow.
Oh. Oh my God,
I didn't know there were
hundreds of people here.
Stadium seating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Pete, Pete,
Pete.
Thousands.
They'll do whatever you say.
Pete, Pete, Pete, Pete.
Loyal. Very loyal.
Watch, they'll do Judd too.
Judd, Judd, Judd, Judd, Judd,
Judd
It got quiet.
Judd, Judd.
We can even do last names.
It took them a second.
Apatow.
Apatow, Apatow, Apatow.
See? You can switch it up.
They're good.
Can they do blood?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Like a scary one?
Sure, sure.
Yeah, it's a
Blood, blood, blood,
blood, blood.
They've been drinking.
Yeah,
been drinking.
We're all vaped up.
I would ... No.
I mean, you could be
in a vape commercial, Jay.
I mean, I would buy it.
Not even for the weed ones.
The ones where he looks
at the guys.
I look like everybody
in those videos of guys
making that fancy vape.
You ever seen fancy vape videos?
I've never realized that.
Yeah, you look like-
Yes. My kids have shown me
people do amazing smoke things.
But those things like the Juul
are the most addictive
thing on the earth,
and all middle schoolers
are like crack heads with Juuls.
That's my question
for you as a parent.
Because I started smoking at 12,
but I was smoking cigarettes.
So Juuls now for middle
school kids, it's less-
You sound like you started
smoking when you were 12.
Yeah Pete, I'm only
25 years old.
My daughter told me last night-
I'm 22.
First of all,
my favorite thing was this-
I didn't mean to interrupt
your anecdote.
Oh no.
This isn't the kind of show
where you can jab in
and have them finish.
Yeah, no.
Jump all in, dude.
Fire away.
This is sloppy.
We have no structure here.
My daughter said last night ...
Because [Christine 00:02:34]
was looking for her Juul,
and my daughter goes,
"Juul, is that
the long rectangle one?"
Like shut the fuck up.
Shut up. Shut up, dork.
You know you have.
She absolutely knows
which one is,
but didn't they say
her school ...
I don't if this
is dangerous or not.
Are they magnetizing
the bathroom
because it makes the Juuls
won't work or something, right?
That's troubling ...
They put detectors.
When you have to magnetize
the whole space.
Yeah. That's what I'm saying.
They've polarized
the entire room.
We've put one fatal flaw
inside of the Juuls.
Guys, is it just me,
or is my Juul not working?
It's like a pyramid
where if you touch this one
brick the whole thing goes down.
My Juul's operating under
the fourth prime directive.
Do not work in school.
Dude, that's a fucking
hilarious thing
to equip the bathrooms
with anti-Juul ...
That's what I always appreciate.
They said Wawa made
all the lights ...
the lighting
in their bathrooms blue
so you can't find a vein
to shoot up heroin
in the bathroom.
Really?
And they make a quality sandwich
24/7.
How big of a junkie was the guy
that pitched that?
He goes, "Guys, I mean,
we could do blue lights.
Can't find a vein
if you wanna shoot some H."
Whoa.
I'm trying to stay clean.
I feel like there's
a whole world
I don't know much about.
Yeah.
Oh, gas station sandwiches
is our specialty.
Oh, Wawa bathrooms?
Wawa bathroom lighting?
Wait, what's a Wawa?
Wawa is a east coast-
A child asking for water?
No.
It could be.
It's a east coast sandwich shop.
East coast sandwich.
But it's a sandwich ...
It's a gas station
sandwich shop.
Oh, so it's a gas station?
Yes.
Well, it's a sandwich shop
first and foremost, Pete.
Yeah.
Show a little respect.
I would say you go
for the sandwiches,
and if you need to refill,
it just so happens
to be a location.
No, you start selling unleaded,
that's your number one.
I mean, they also
do diesel, so let's not
paint them in a corner.
That's how they lure you in.
Then you get into the store.
Look at this store.
You calling that a gas station?
You saying that's a gas station
right there?
You've never been more Philly
than you are right now.
Yeah.
That's a store!
I feel like if you're a long ...
you're a trucker and you're
driving long distances,
you want food
that clogs you up.
Yeah.
You don't want food
that keeps it moving.
Yeah.
Regularity?
If you're a trucker
and your route
has blessed you
by passing a Wawa
and you don't stop in there ...
I mean, unless you're
looking to shoot heroin.
Yeah, that's looks
like a
How funny would that be
if you're just with someone
and you go, "Can't go to Wawa.
They got blue lights."
And you're like, "Hey D, are you
going through something?"
He's like, "That's fine.
No, I smoke meth,
so it doesn't matter.
I don't need lights."
He goes, "I actually like
the blue lights.
They calm me down.
They take me down
from my violent stage."
What else would the blue lights
stop you from doing?
I don't know.
That's it.
Blowing a Smurf (bleep)
It'd make a poster look sick.
And also wear a t-shirt
with a mustard stain on it.
You'd go, "I thought ...
Son of a bitch, I thought
this thing came out."
What would it do?
Show all of your fake teeth?
Show all of your dental flaws?
That does look like a store
you'd have to be road hypnotized
by a 90 mile haul
to think it's a store.
Or be Jay.
I wish we could ... Yeah.
You could just be Jay
looking to tailgate.
Yeah, or just be Jay.
I wish we had Wawa sandwiches
for you guys
both to eat in front of us to-
I'm good on diarrhea.
There's no diarrhea
involved here.
As you said, stopping up.
It's gonna clog you.
Clog it up. It's the cork.
I don't even feel cloggy.
I think it almost
makes you regular.
It's fantastic food.
But what if you're a trucker
and you're like okay,
I gotta drive.
I've got 2000 miles ahead of me.
And then you get in your car
and you have your coffee,
and then 30 seconds later
you're like,
I gotta take a shit.
But that happens every
20 minutes for 2000 miles.
You put it in second gear.
That's the code
for filling up them trousers.
Oh really?
You go, "I think this guy
in front of me's downshifting."
Pete, I didn't know
you spoke CB.
You speak ham radio?
He goes, "Why? Do you got a guy
on the line with you?"
He goes, "Breaker, breaker,
one, two.
Yeah, are you shifting
down into second
to drop a load in your pants?"
Yeah.
Did you just drop a ham radio?
I dropped a full ham radio.
Jay, has anyone ever thought
when you said,
"My name is Big Jay Oakerson,"
that you were spelling it out
and that it was Jokerson
with a capital J?
Yes.
What's your name? Big J.
Big Jokerson.
Oakerson.
Yeah, start with the J,
then go Oakerson.
That'll get you all there.
I never noticed it myself
until somebody would
just make my name on ...
When I did the ...
starting the black circuit,
sometimes they would
just write "Big"
and then the letter J.
That's not how I ever thought.
I was always-
Like Big Jay.
Yeah, I
But this was the letter J.
So Big J Oakerson
looks like Big Jokerson.
Is it true ... Yes.
Wasn't Bill Burr, when he did
the black circuit, Billy Burr?
Wasn't that his thing?
I think he was Billy Burr
across the board, and then one
Across the board Billy Burr.
His headshot at The Cellar
says "Billy Burr."
It does?
Yeah.
Can I tell-
I think one day he just said,
"How old do you have to get
and still be called Billy?"
Hilarious.
That was it.
It's what he told me.
He was like, "Yeah, I can't
be called Billy anymore."
I only ever knew Bill
as the greatest and a legend.
And I opened for him
when I was first starting out,
and he was headlining.
It was at Peoria.
It was a place called The Ice
House or something in Peoria.
It doesn't matter.
So I get back to ...
I get to New York.
I see Gaffigan.
This is 10, 15 years ago,
and I go, yeah,
I was just in blah,
blah opening for Bill Burr."
And he goes, "Billy Burr?"
It was so long ago
that he couldn't believe
that Bill Burr was headlining.
Really?
He knew him. Can you ...
Just let that soak in.
There was a time that we knew
Bill Burr as a strong middle.
He can't believe
Judah Friedlander's headlining
now either apparently.
Dude, that's hilarious
just to think there was a time
that someone was like,
"Richie Pryor
You're gonna have
that guy fucking ... "
That's what I'm saying!
Little Dick Pryor?
I think that's what Merv Griffin
called him
on the first appearance.
Oh really? It was Richie Pryor?
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Let's welcome Little
Richie Pryor.
Georgie Carlin
is looking to do an ...
That guy's doing an hour?
He's never gonna be able
to fill an hour.
Billy Cosby, a real lady
killer in the back.
What do you think
he's doing right now?
Bill Cosby?
Oh man, fucking sharpening
the back of a toothbrush,
fucking get extra cornbread.
Here's what I was-
(bleep)
I was trying to figure out,
is he bragging about
being Bill Cosby
or trying to tell people
he's not Bill Cosby?
I don't know.
No, I think they have him
in a wing
where he doesn't see
any other gen pop.
Gen pop.
Yeah, he's not in there.
He's not in there
with the animals.
He's in
I think he's got that milky eye
just sitting in a corner
telling old war stories
smoking a cigar.
Are you familiar with the 70s?
Son, pull up your pants.
He's still telling him pull up
their pants in fucking prison.
They go, "Yo man,
I murdered a guy."
I speak English.
I speak English, and the Ebonics
will not work
in this certain play area.
Cell block D speaks English.
Why is the light blue
in the bathroom?
Is it for the veins?
Have you ever looked for your
veins and you can't find them?
Where are my veins?
Where did they go?
You're looking for the veins
and the
We were trying to think
of the worst stand up material
that you could do for
Dov Davidoff for his character
Jason, and what we landed on
On Crashing HBO.
On Crashing for HBO.
30th
at 10 p.m.
Comedy Central Radio Sirius,
this is Big Jay.
There you go.
And what we decided
was the worst bit that we made
a stand up bit out of was
Bill Cosby's graduation speech
from a long time ago
where his big running joke
was that he was mocking
the concept of consent.
And that was his thing.
So you gotta ask people?
How's that gonna work?
And he literally did a whole
routine at a graduation.
Jesus.
That's fucking ...
Cosby did?
Yes.
Wait, that's a real thing?
No, yeah, and it's in a book.
He put it in one of his books.
Cosby mocked consent
at a fucking ...
Talk about ...
I didn't know that.
That's what serial killers
do to fucking wave a thumb
in the nose
of the detectives.
Yeah.
The level of sociopath ...
I left you all the clues.
You ignored them for years.
Just when they busted in his
house in Philadelphia he goes,
"It took you long enough.
I've had the clues
out there for years."
He turned in a chair
and he goes,
"Gentlemen, I've been expecting
you since the late 70s."
What took you gentlemen so long?
I've gone through
several plates of jello.
The bodies were all there.
Everything was there.
Even I started to believe
I didn't do it.
There it is.
He's the snowman killer.
That's what you're saying.
Yeah, exactly.
That's exactly it. They say-
Yeah, here it is.
There's a whole article
they're pulling up.
Wow.
Where they found
his weird speech.
Yeah, in the book Cosby
tells readers
how lucky they are
to have graduated
since they no longer have
to deal with campus sex police.
In a chapter titled "No More
Pre-Caressing Agreements,"
Cosby describes how silly it is
that men need to get permission
to have sexual relations
with women they find attractive.
I mean, say what you will about
Bill Cosby.
Guy stayed on brand
for decades.
The guy operated on
Cromag law.
Yeah. Cave man law.
law.
Flip them over to the dome
and drag them by their feet
so you don't mess up the
and get the hair
dragging with the
I mean, it's fucking crazy.
They gotta keep him
by himself in prison.
Yeah.
Because everyone ...
I bet there's a lot of people
that are like-
Because they'll fuck anybody.
Yeah. They're like,
"I wanna fuck Dr. Huxtable."
But he probably wants to be
around people
so he can tell his stories
and brag and ...
"I was into I Spy."
And they're like, "Yeah, we saw
it. It's an Owen Wilson movie."
"No, it was a Robert Cope"
Dammit. I wonder if-
Now only one of my eyes can spy.
Yeah. I wonder if he pitched
a stand up night to the guys
just to try to get his set in?
Oh, I bet he did.
He goes, "Maybe for moral
I can go up there
and tell some jokes about
how I took the ladies
and I put them to the sleep
You can only do material
about your conviction.
Yeah. It's like fucking
talent night in the ...
Now you do 20 minutes
about that murder.
Richie over here is an arson.
He's gonna tell everybody
how he feels
when he sees the buildings
burning and the crackling
and the
Rashad over here did a drive by
and got the driving
and the shooting and the bipping
and the booping
and the bopping.
Him just describing,
he becomes ...
You know how they always find
some old wise guy in prison
to help them with
their fucking ... to get ...
Yeah, to become a Muslim.
Yeah, but to make bail.
We were talking about that
with Jimmy Martinez.
I wonder if Cosby
becomes their ...
Because he's a doctor.
They're like, "Hey doctor,
can you help me out?"
"What did you do?"
And trying to argue him
in front of the parole board.
Because he's a stand up.
You know he misses
doing stand up.
He must want a gaggle of people
around him all day long.
I don't think he's
sitting alone in there.
He's trying
to volunteer somehow.
Yeah, I'd probably
try to pony up to him.
I'll do the laundry.
You would?
You'd protect the Cos?
And if I was like ...
If I was in there-
Oh, pony up on him.
Does that mean attack him?
No, no, no.
I'd try to be friends with him
because you know there'd
probably be some good security.
This guy with his gen pop.
I don't know what he's
saying half the time.
Listen Pete, some of us
got some dark pasts.
I speak English. Have you been
to prison? You've never been-
Some of us eat Wawa and some
of us were in some gangs
we're not too proud of,
but you do it to survive.
You think the ultimate
punishment
is he has to eat off
brand pudding in prison now?
No, they just make it. They go-
It's viscus in a way
I don't care for.
Can they please
be given to me sealed?
I don't trust you.
But that is a hard thing
when you've been eating
from your personal chef
for 50 years.
Yeah.
That's gotta be part of what is
unpleasant about his situation.
And the beds ... The beds ...
He's been wealthy
for over four decades,
so his beds are this
thick in paddings,
and now he's just on
that slime ... that thin slab.
If you think Wawa is a store,
you won't mind prison.
Yeah. That's actually been
our motto our whole-
But if you've been having
a personal chef,
like an omelet chef
every morning ...
If you think Wawa's a store,
you're just correct.
And you just have traveled
this great land.
If prison food
is like Wawa food,
well then sign this guy up.
I'm gonna shoot this guy
in the head.
Yeah.
Right now.
What do you wanna do?
Off DJ Lou?
Yeah, I'll do it on camera.
I'll do it on camera.
You telling me I get
Wawa everyday
and I get to talk to the Cos?
I get to write my slam poems?
But you know somewhere
there's a lab for all
the Wa food,
and there's a moment
where one of the heads
of the company
is trying the new hamburger.
Yeah.
[inaudible 00:14:28] like,
"This is fantastic."
You know there's a massive
process for every product there.
Yeah. Oh absolutely.
And they do little
test tube drops.
Now that tastes like ranch.